the top stories on sky world news the
World Health Organization is predicting
that up to 4 million people could be
infected with the Zika virus this year
the virus spread by mosquitoes has been
linked to brain defects in babies the
Italian Coast Guard has released
dramatic pictures of the rescue of a
family who are on a sinking boat near
the Greek island of Samos at least 25
other migrants have drowned in the same
area Republican presidential frontrunner
Donald Trump has held his own rally as
the rest of the candidates battled it
out in their final TV debate in Iowa
more now on our top story the outbreak
of the Zika virus in South America the
World Health Organization is warning
that it could spread globally and
explosively so just how serious is the
risk for the rest of the world skies Ian
woods has more at the new screen well
the virus was first detected in Uganda
in 1947 but no regular outbreaks were
reported until 2013 this pandemic
started in Brazil in May of last year in
just eight months it is infected an
estimated 1.5 million people in Brazil
and this week came confirmation that it
has spread to 22 countries across South
and Central America that's twice as many
as a week ago and it now includes
Barbados and Mexico even though Zika is
usually mild the evidence linking it to
brain-damaged babies means that the
governments of Jamaica Colombia and El
Salvador have gone as far as advising
women to consider delay in their
pregnancies for a year or two and the
World Health Organization says the
outbreak will spread across the whole of
the Americas potentially creating 3 to 4
million cases over the next year the
explosive spread of Zika virus to new
geographical areas with little
population immunity is another cause for
concern especially given the possible
link between infection during pregnancy
and babies born with small heads up to
now it's thought he was only transmitted
by bites from the ieds group of
mosquitoes that can only survive in
tropical or sub
tropical regions like these but it's now
force it could also be transmitted by
the much more common collects mosquito
there are 20 times more of them around
the world taking not just in the
Americas but also parts of Africa and
Asia the World Health Organization is
holding an emergency meeting on Monday
to decide if the Zika virus outbreak
should be declared an international
health emergency
well we're joined now by Professor Peter
J hotel's Dean for the National School
of Tropical Medicine at Baylor College
of Medicine in Houston Texas if I can
start off by asking you professor just
how easily could the Zika virus spread
from South America to the rest of the
world well thanks for having me on so
we're seeing an incredibly rapid spread
this was introduced into Brazil a year
ago there's more than a million people
infected you're 700,000 in Colombia and
you can just watch the virus move up to
the tropical regions of South America
then at the Central America now to the
Caribbean so I believe that by the end
of February the entire Caribbean will be
affected so this is a fast-moving virus
something very impressive what's so
scary of course is to link to birth
defects so we're seeing large numbers of
babies being born with this horrific
congenital birth defect known as
microcephaly and so we've got to take
some very dramatic measures to stop this
virus but the w-h-o is not definitely
linking this microcephaly to the virus
yet I mean if it isn't the virus then
what could be causing these birth
defects well it's looking pretty
clear-cut so what we're seeing is that
you can isolate the virus from the
babies that have microcephaly not all of
them but many of them you can find it in
the amniotic fluid of mothers with this
in the placentas so we don't have all
our eyes dotted and t's crossed but how
else do you explain this 20-fold
increase the presence of the virus and
temporarily coincides when the virus got
introduced in the Americas so the point
is I don't think we can wait for the
final eye to be dotted in the T to be
crossed we have to implement public
health measures right now and is there
something of that I know this is very
different from Ebola but the fact that
we're hearing language like explosive
from the w-h-o are they trying to
ahead of this because they were
obviously criticized for for their
response to to Ebola earlier on in the
outbreak yeah it's easy to criticize
them and say this is an overreaction
from their previous under reaction but I
don't think this is the case I think
they're being measured and I think
they're absolutely right I think there's
it's there's a good chance now this is
gonna go into the Gulf Coast of the
United States remember we have no window
period to be wrong many of these cases
are asymptomatic so unless we intervene
right now if we wait for nine months for
babies to be warm from microcephaly then
it's gonna be too late we can't make the
same error that happened in Brazil
happened in the rest of the Americas so
we have to intervene right now and in
terms of the search for a vaccine this
is a standing start isn't it whereas
with Ebola that there was a bit of run
up time if you will yeah I mean we're at
least two years away from a vaccine we
make you know here in Texas Children's
Hospital where Maine Sabin vaccine is -
we're making vaccines in the nonprofit
sector we make the vaccines that the
drug companies won't make it's at least
two years away maybe three years so we
have to go back to old-fashioned public
health control measures the good note
the good news is that they work so we
know for instance that when South
America was faced with a terrible
epidemic of dengue and yellow fever in
the 50s and 60s they went on a
military-style campaign to eradicate the
80s a chipped a mosquito and it worked
are they they eliminated the mosquito in
18 countries and stopped dengue fever
and yellow fever for a period of time we
could do that again and delay things
long enough till we get a vaccine but
it's going to require a very aggressive
measures we're going to need a great
leader a field marshal that's gonna want
to lead these efforts so it's not gonna
be easy it's not gonna be it's gonna be
tough love but I think it has to be done
professor Peter J hotels thank you very
much indeed for your insight